what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so picking up with really the
conclusion of God love God loves me and
kills which by the way I've got a cold
you guys could probably tell I'm
actually getting over it but still it
sucks anyway picking up with God loves
man kills the the conclusion of all this
we switch over to Charles Xavier
now this is where you really start to
see how screwed up William Stryker is
when this happens we basically switch
over to Manhattan to the to the
headquarters of the Stryker who saved
and one of the things they say you know
the really kind of gets thrown in here
is and then they brought they bring him
under the place Golgotha and they
crucified that is a testament to Jesus
Jesus was crucified there now the idea
behind this is that when this happens
with Xavier with him being crucified
it's all the x-men who show up and
literally start like stabbing him deal
jabbing at him ripping his heart out
there's all these forms of psychic
torture now in reality this is not truly
happening but this is the worst
conceivable nightmare for Charles Xavier
and that's one of the things to bear in
mind is that for Charles Xavier there's
really kind of like two aspects of what
it is that he does you've got the x-men
so basically creating like a peaceful
coexistence between humans and mutants
and then you've got the x-men as his
actual children is really how he sees
them and the way that William Stryker
plays this out is that in the midst of
all this torture in this this place of
darkness and pain that he kind of shows
up is a savior of sorts it says look
surrender yourself to me and everything
will be okay give yourself to me and in
turn I will lead you to paradise very
much presenting himself as God or as a
guy as a christ-like figure because it
really fits well within the religious
themes of William Stryker and the role
that he plays the issue with this is
that Charles Xavier resists to a degree
now is one of these things this has been
going on for fifteen hours and so
there's no sight that there's really no
end in sight and that's the nature of
William Stryker when he goes in and he
starts talking to Philip Ramsey who's
like a psychologist who's the one
implementing all the psychological
torture the results here are that Xavier
is slowly being broken down now the
other the other part of this of course
that you have Cyclops and you have storm
and the question is asked to them is why
are you doing this
but what's the basis behind all this in
the first place do you really just hate
mutants that much and the response of
William Stryker is is kind of amazing
here and this is where you start to see
you know Fox having drawn their elements
from its character but not really taking
the next step for fear of pissing off
all the Christians but the idea here is
that originally William Stryker was a
member of the u.s. military and when he
had finally finished his you know his
leave where I guess is his tour
basically or at least when he was on
break from his tour he and his wife were
travelling when of course she was
pregnant and then began to give birth to
their child you know in the midst of
car wreck that they experienced when the
when the birthday process began and the
child was actually born William Stryker
realized it was a mutant and believing
that it was had killed the child now
when his wife asked for the baby he in
turn broke her neck this is a man that
killed his own wife and child is extreme
now we're this originally stemmed from
fear he in turn got into the vehicle and
then lit a match and him to kill both
all of them in the process and he was
blown free from the from the entire
explosion and in his mind he
rationalized God saved me from this fate
God wants me to go forward and destroy
all these mutants now the other part of
this is this goes into a guy by the name
of Fred Duncan now Fred Duncan was a
character who's created by Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby and he originally appeared
with like the Vanisher first showed up
when it comes to model is one of things
Barry mom when it comes to Marvel Comics
you oftentimes see liaisons right like
when x-factor first not really when they
first showed up when the the original
x-men left x-factor and a new team was
brought in in the early 1990s you got
Valerie Cooper and then you got forged
you basically had these characters who
were like liaisons between x-factor and
E and the federal government with Fred
Duncan he was a liaison between the FBI
and the xmin themselves and so it was
kind of like a give-and-take you he'd be
one of those guys who basically warned
the x-men if something was coming down
the pipe that could threaten them where
they were they were gonna be needed but
he was also a character who the x-bow
would relay information to on their
various goings on and things that were
happening now where this was kind of
like a tenuous relationship and where
Fred Duncan was more of a friend of of
Xavier and the rights of the x-men
didn't truly trust him when events began
to unfold like the like the formation of
project wide-awake when he started
getting into the the federal government
basically using the FBI the NSA the CIA
all these various organizations for the
purpose of like spying on the mutant
threat trying to contain and control at
Fred Duncan would pass information to
the x-men and basically become more of a
friend kind of giving them a step ahead
of what the federal government was doing
but the fact remains here this is one of
the things that William Stryker was
doing was that he had a member of the
Stryker who stayed working in the FBI
and that member was taking information
that was being gained by Fred Duncan and
pulling it in and giving it to William
Stryker the purifiers are all over the
place
anybody could be one of these guys it's
like a modern-day Klan except they don't
wear white hoods and white outfits and
all that kind of crazy stuff so again
it's pretty extreme and it's pretty dark
now what we also have to remember here
is is that Kitty Pryde he basically
stowed away alongside with the purifiers
when they showed up at the Xavier
Institute while the rest of the x-men or
away and kidnap Illyana Rasputin the
sister of Colossus and so when this
happened of course Kitty Pryde location
was like the purifiers were aware of
there they essentially use nerve gas to
knock her out but when they actually get
to the location when the question is
asked you know Sir William Stryker
we have Illyana Rasputin what do you
wanted to do with kitty pryde he says
killer the guys willing to kill a 15
year old girl it's a it's extreme now of
course Kitty Pryde makes her escape but
the problem with this is that she still
suffering from the effects of nerve gas
which hasn't totally worn off yet
and so her phasing powers aren't at 100%
she's literally just kind of fleeing for
her life and so in this instance when
Kitty Pryde basically makes your way
into the Bronx she ends up running
across a gang and of course we know what
the gangs integers are whither despite
the fact that she's 15 years old and so
when they try to make a move and I
basically try to force themselves on her
of course you have an for the purifiers
who shows up who in turn looks to kill
Kitty Pryde now this is the nature of
the purifiers they'll kill whoever gets
in their way
it doesn't matter who you are if you are
in the way of them and a mutant they
will kill you to get to that mute is how
extreme they are and so of course an
intern kills all the gang members Kitty
Pryde manages to make her escape and
then of course calls Nightcrawler back
at the Xavier Institute and says hey
here's where I am and then of course
there's a massive explosion the
purifiers are still chasing her down
that's the intensity that goes on here
yes the purifiers are human yes they
tired but KT prize in a weakened state
they will constantly chase her until
they finally get a hold of her it's the
nature of who they are and so in this
moment you know when she finally manages
the stowaway aboard a subway train and
manages to make her escape but the
purifiers track her down they chased her
down they try to take her out and of
course that leads to the arrival of
Colossus will rein Nightcrawler all nine
yards and they basically take out these
purifiers and of course is a survivor
she manages to make her escape but it's
still pretty extreme because then you
switch back over to Charles Xavier and
this is where the the continued mental
torture of Charles Xavier has begun to
finally take its toll that the the
psychic torture he's been experiencing
has slowly been eroding away at his
mental blocks to the point that when
William Stryker finally steps in and
says are you ready to embrace the Word
of God are you ready to become a
believer in the power of Christ that
that in turn Xavier response is yes and
the William Stryker says then kill
Cyclops and storm and where he initially
resist what wave sucker does here is he
says only those who are worthy will be
accepted only those who are worthy will
be viewed by me as being worthy so if
you truly want to to attain the splendor
of heaven if you truly want to attain
something greater then you have to kill
them and Charles Xavier says okay and he
kills Cyclops and storm and it is
mind-blowing when this happened like I
remember reading this actually the
animated series my dad introduced me to
comic books and I in turn start reading
every
thing I possibly can't what I'm reading
this all blew me away and it's like okay
Xavier is ready because what they're
gonna do is they're gonna go to this
garden this massive event that they're
putting on like a giant Church sermon
and what's gonna go on behind the scenes
is Xavier mind is gonna pick up everyone
who's a mutant and all those mutants who
were there are gonna be killed by Xavier
and so what you end up having like
philip ramsey who basically gets in his
vehicle and leaves to go back and change
get a shower so on and so forth and then
head to the garden proper he's
intercepted by kurt wagner now this is
where Nightcrawler begins to show his
darker half where he really is more of
like a loving and a gentle character
when it comes down to it
Nightcrawler could scare the hell out of
you because of how he looks I mean if
you got someone that shows up to you
looking like a devil and then starts
teleporting you around the world it's
gonna scare you out of your wits and
that's literally what he does with
Philip he snatches him up and says like
I'm here to inflict pain and torture I'm
here to take all the nightmares you've
ever had of what might know of what
mutants are and I'm here to bring them
to your doorstep we have a lot of ways
that we can make you hurt we have even
more ways that we can kill you so which
one is it gonna be do you want to hurt
or do you want to die and so ultimately
Philip Ramsey hands the information over
it's where you end up having you know
the bodies of storm in Cyclops who were
unceremoniously thrown on these beds and
then carted down to the incinerators you
end up having like the elevator was just
like jerks up to the top because they
have Illyana Rasputin going with them
you know it's like it literally jerks to
the top and just plunges out of the
building only for us to find out magneto
was the one who's doing it and so and
the purifier jumps out of the elevator
grabs onto the edge of the building
flees for a life and then you have like
Wolverine who sits down and says they're
not dead now to be honest and this is a
bit of a MacGuffin
but that's the nature of Chris Claremont
storytelling right like Chris Claremont
doesn't tell this for shock value with
Chris Claremont when he wrote these
stories the way that he when he did
things like this it was designed for the
purpose to show how bad things were
it's designed to show you how broken
Charles Xavier is well then the question
becomes if they're not dead why are they
not dead and the answer to this question
is because Charles Xavier is still
fighting back there's still some part of
him this fighting back his best he can't
and so what are you decisional ii done
will shut down the minds of storm and
Cyclops as far as anybody out there
using machines to read them was aware
they were dead because their mental
patterns were operating at such a low
rate that they would seem to be dead
it's a cool little thing to see because
it shows the bond between Xavier and the
x-men that is this unbreakable thing did
Xavier while he died has done some shady
things well he has dozens of things that
maybe seem like betrayal the one thing
he would not do is kill his own x-men
stories like these are why events like
Avengers vs. x-men would Cyclops
Hills Xavier is so significant with
Xavier being in the mental state that
William Stryker expect him to be in
that's one of the important things to
bear in mind Xavier is finding is such a
way to where subconsciously he'll
preserve the x-men who are you talking
about the rest of the mutant population
and Xavier does not care for the rest of
the medon population the way he does
care for the x-men and so this is still
a tangible possibility that Xavier will
be brought to the garden that he'll
he'll be put on display for the world to
see that William Stryker will use him to
kill all the mutants in this immediate
vicinity turn him into a weapon and then
internally it's really just kind of a
testbed will this work in this immediate
area and if it will well then in turn
like I can espouses and say see guys God
hates mutants look at this because no
one's gonna know that Xavier is the one
that's doing it just gonna be like hey
guys God hates mutants like look at look
at God's smiting the mutant population
so again it's extreme remember that's
the nature of William Stryker well all
that's happening the power of Xavier is
being put to work and all these various
mutants are being made to suffer
Thermage being scrambled or they're
really on the verge of being killed you
have magneto who fights back as best he
can't but there's only so much that he
can do one of the things to bear in mind
here though is the nature of the people
who were attending when it comes to
something like this when it comes to
extreme views extreme views draw
extremists and extreme views make
extremists out of non extreme people as
though it's literally fear-mongering is
telling people exactly what they want to
hear that's exactly what William Stryker
does here and it works stupendously
because in a state of desperation people
will believe what they want to believe
and so you've already got people who
already have this sort of basis you know
baseline hatred for the mutant
population William Stryker comes along
and says behold a power of Christ
amplifies that mutant hatred and then in
turn uses that fear to amplify their
fear and hate even more it's one of the
best political maneuvers a person can
make so that's one reason why Chris
Claremont storytelling was incredibly
political it was always political it was
never not political but it was always
cool the way that it was done as well
you have the x-men basically trying to
fight off as best they can the only
people who are being affected here are
mutants and so what this means is that
with Charles Xavier mind working it's
kind of like a beacon it's kind of a
radar it kind of reveals the the hidden
mutant population among them one of whom
is an who's actually one of the members
of the purifiers
what a mutant power is we don't know
we're never told but William Stryker
doesn't care and so we're an has been
faithful his best soldier to this point
he pushes her off the platform she falls
it breaks her neck and that's the end of
ant this unceremonious into an otherwise
devoted follower who turned out to be a
mutant that's just the way this game
gets played and so as a result the
devices that are being used
kind of amplify the power of Xavier are
taken out by cyclops and in doing so
that leads to the rest of the x-men kind
of asked in the question what do we do
now and the initial response is a we can
kill William Stryker but the response of
Cyclops is no we're not going to kill
him what we're going to do is we're
going to discredit him and that's the
best move that he can make and the
reason why is because you're talking
about this massive gathering is being
televised all across the world
if the x-men walked in there and killed
him it wouldn't make him a martyr and so
Cyclops walks in and says we have to
debate him we have to destroy his
credibility on TV and reduces argument
down to nothing that's the best way to
win because winning the hearts and minds
of people is not done through physical
violence and so when you have the
Cyclops who goes in and says hey look
we're gonna have a debate we're gonna
argue with you
his response is like yes we're mutants
but like we're also human beings too we
have abilities but our our abilities so
different from like a world-class
astronomer or a master chess player are
they really that different these gifts
sure manifests in a physical way and
some of them are dangerous but just like
any other circumstance a villain like a
criminal with a handgun a gangbanger
a doctor the practices euthanasia
whatever the case is we have an ability
we have a gift and we can use it for
good or evil there are those of us who
use it for evil and those of us who use
it for good but does that mean that
every gun owner is a bad guy does it
mean that every gun owner is a criminal
of course it doesn't it means that there
are those who own guns and there are
those who are going to commit bad acts
with them but just because a person can
do a bad thing doesn't mean they will do
a bad thing we are not an inherently
evil group of people but that's the
nature of extremist views extremist
views do not see great areas it's a very
very dangerous ideology to have and
because he scored in this argument
because of the fact that he's that he's
told by my Cyclops look for all you know
it could be that we're baseline humans
and that you're the mutation that
everybody that that people are supposed
to be born with powers you know because
I mean suck cops is really kind of
talking about as a stat point but it's
like people are born with powers you are
born without powers so what if you're a
mutation here and even if that's not the
case we are the next step in human
evolution men were Apes once and that
literally is an affront to everything
William Stryker beliefs divine creation
God created heaven the earth firmament
need all that kind of good stuff and in
his desperation he does the only thing
he knows how to do he turns to violence
and he literally pulls a gun and points
it at 80 probably the intention of
shooting her and the x-men stand down
they stand there and do nothing because
what this does is it shows that the
argument of William Stryker has no
mirror there's no real ground tour
distantly him just espousing nonsense
under the belief
that like people will believe him and
when there's nothing left when when the
foundation of his argument is literally
destroyed
he turns to violence violence is an act
of desperation and it's an act of
desperation by desperate men and women
when they have nothing else they'll turn
to violence the xmin stand down and they
shot by a cop and one of the cops is
just like he was gonna shoot a 15 year
old unarmed trial not a chance I was
gonna let that happen this cop does his
duty he shoots William Stryker is this
be actually have done nothing wrong here
the x-men are our victims of an
otherwise deranged man who believes big
God wants him to kill mutants this guy
was gonna kill innocent people I shot
this guy he's gonna go to jail the x-men
you're free to go your victims of a
kidnapping and torture just just get out
of here and so following that what this
does is this leads to this really really
interesting scenario we kind of go into
this epilogue and you basically have
like the aftermath of all this and
William strugglers taken to jail and so
on and so forth and the x-men are
talking to Charles Xavier and Charles
Xavier starts to adopt the mindset of
Magneto and this comes out of Charles
Xavier
Charles Xavier experience the guy was
tortured consistently for almost a full
24 hours he was psychologically tortured
and it almost destroyed his perception
of humanity what happens when you
encounter a man who is so fanatical who
is so far gone that his belief system is
derived from faith derived from the God
this incorruptible unshakable thing and
he says because of my faith because of
this unshakable belief I am going to
wipe out the entirety of the mutant
population what do you do in the face of
that how do you function in the face of
that what William Stryker showed Charles
Xavier is that there are men out there
whose hearts and minds cannot be changed
they cannot be reasoned with
they can't be bargained with there's
nothing you can do to convince them that
their way is the wrong way that the only
way to really stop them is to kill them
and what that's done is this destroyed
Charles Xavier is procession that a
peaceful coexistence can be achieved
that he sits of this chair and says
maybe Magneto's right maybe there really
is no way to save the hearts and minds
of men because William Stryker wasn't
religious Fundamentalist but what
happens when you have men and women in
positions of power that cannot be
touched they cannot be stopped
akin and sometimes can't even be seen
because their presences are so secretive
what happens when they're the ones whose
hearts and minds can't be changed what
happens when a person decides they want
to press the nuclear option what happens
will you run into that situation how do
you cope with that how do you deal with
that and Xavier Swan says you can't
William Stryker showed me that there
were people out there who just can't be
they can't be convinced and if they
can't be convinced then maybe this is a
this is a fruitless effort maybe it's
pointless but the the argument Cyclops
makes here is no
not William Strucker was one man what do
you have to say about the cop who shot
him what do you have to say about those
who began to look at what William
Stryker was saying as they may be this
really is too extreme maybe this really
is too hardcore my humble against
stopping those who were dangerous but
like I'm not in favor of killing mutant
children who haven't done anything wrong
like how what do you say to those guys
what do you say to them are you gonna
look that cop in the eye you're gonna
say things you're saving my life but
like you're still a credible threat
though like are you really gonna say
that William Stryker was an extremist
example but for every extreme William
Stryker out there there's a cop there's
that one cop with red hair who saved his
life and so because that like you you
can't take it as extreme it's really
Cyclops making the argument saying this
is how you become a William Stryker sure
you're not a religious fundamentalist
who believes that God wants you to kill
mutants but you are becoming like
Magneto and Magneto really is at the end
of the day nothing more than another
William Stryker
but on the opposite end of the spectrum
and that's kind of a mind-blowing
perception to throw out there to see
magneto put in that light but it kind of
make the argument that he really kind of
is the same way and so with his face
kind of fate kind of being shaken xavier
goes forward really kind of having to
ask himself some very serious questions
is it worth it to continue this peaceful
coexistence you know is it the Cyclops
is better suited to leave the x-men than
he is there's these different things
that go in there you have an arguments
that are made and what this does is it
kind of feeds into the future of the
x-men stories under Chris Claremont
going forward for the next 7 years until
Clermont leaves and helps to kind of
build things even further but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explained make sure you guys to
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you
[Music]